five minutes is not enough to tell the
four of you how much i loved this film
congratulations on fire island it was
such a fun movie to watch i had a blast
joel listen you wrote something
so authentic to the queer community it's
obviously dealing with racism and
classism and things like that but it is
also just showing the pure joy of being
queer is that something that you just
wanted to come across on screen because
too often i feel like queer films
are a little dark and depressing i think
that like so much of the media that is
targeted at our community is about our
trauma you know and i think that like
you know that exists within all of us to
a certain degree but i think especially
in the times that we're living in now i
wanted to really showcase
all the joy that i feel you know like i
i i love being gay i love being queer
and i specifically i love it because of
the people that i've surrounded myself
with and so you know uh
my and my times on fire island have been
sort of emblematic of that like the the
big the the most i've i felt welcome and
at home with my chosen family has been
on fire island and so that's really the
big reason i wanted to write that right
that movie
well it like i said it is fantastic look
i've never been to fire island i want to
go so bad i'm going to plan a trip there
but i need to know from each of you if i
were going to fire island in my speedo
what would be in my survival kit you
each have to give me one thing for my
fire island survival kit has to fit in
the speedo
no it doesn't have to fit in the sphero
i'm just going to i'm just going to be
in my speed
a fanny pack i was going to say a
bluetooth speaker you take it to the
beach with you play some tunes or you'd
be bring it back to the house
yeah um a book you can read that will
inspire you to write a movie based on
that book
noise cancelling headphones
[Laughter]
i would say lube
that's very important very important to
pack in that survival kit food
shelter lube
joel and bowen i know you have spent
time on fire island together so you know
let's give et canada a little tea what
was the wildest thing that happened on
fire island with the two of you how
chemically specific yeah
listen baby this is in canada you tell
me the tea and we are gonna put it out
there wow um i think it was probably
doing lsd
and actually watching a house
move inland during the actual physically
be lifted and moved um and this is not
the lsd talking we actually
did that house just move
and um and it did and it did yeah so um
i don't know it's a beautiful um
that was a beautiful
moment beautiful moment indeed bowen
listen i feel like you're part of my
chosen family because i spend every
saturday night with you oh i am oh
listen i am such a fan of you i'm a fan
of all of you you are all doing
incredible things for the queer
community but outside of that just in
entertainment so bowen you are part of
my chosen family i used to go out and
party on saturday nights and now my
favorite thing to do is sit down and
watch snl how boring i know
but listen two of my favorite cast
members 80 and kate are leaving you have
had so many iconic sketches with them
how hard was it to say goodbye really
really hard and um i mean they're two of
the best people to do it i think two
people who like comported themselves so
well during their time there
made it a better place to work you know
uplifted people
um so it'll be it'll be different it'll
be a change i haven't envisioned what
it's like to work there without them so
we'll see
well you are fantastic on that show
again time is running out i can talk to
you forever about this movie
congratulations congratulations thank
you for making this film if there's ever
a fire island too you know maybe uh
dallas dixon can come to set and do that
yeah
[Laughter]
i love it thank you so much all of you